British Prime Minister Theresa May and
her government are facing a
no-confidence vote later today after
lawmakers throughout her brexit deal it
was the biggest the most humiliating
defeat in modern British history and it
casts even greater uncertainty over when
how and even if Britain will withdraw
from the European Union well at the
moment the Prime Minister is taking her
weekly questions in Parliament but this
time the stakes are high indeed with me
here in the studio we are joined by DW
Briggs at analysts Alex Forrest whiting
who is going to talk with us in just a
moment but first we were actually going
to go to the live feed and now Alex and
the House of Commons and then we'd like
to get your reaction thereafter
honourable former colleague will find
that that is an accurate interpretation
of the government's positions and my
colleagues like the right all right the
honourable gentleman for banff in buckin
has argued strongly for that case and we
will see what happens when the bill
returns a report stage order questions
to the prime minister Charlie elf a
number one mr. speaker the prime
minister q mr. speaker
I am sure that the whole house will join
me in condemning the appalling attack in
Nairobi and in sending my thoughts and
prayers to all those who have lost loved
ones our High Commissioner has confirmed
one British fatality and we're providing
consular assistance to British nationals
affected by the attack we stand in
solidarity with the government and
people of Kenya and will continue to
offer our support to meet the challenge
to security and stability that is posed
by terrorism in the region mr. speaker
this morning I have meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
Charlie elphic Thank You mr. speaker may
I join with the Prime Minister in her
strong condemnation of terror and so you
will know mr. speaker and the premier
sir will know that I first sought
election to this house because I
believed in more jobs lower taxes a
stronger economy the more investment in
the public services on which we all rely
on does she agree that since 2010
Conservative government's have delivered
time and again for the British people
and the biggest threat to that it's sat
on the opposition front bench with a
leader whose policies would mean less
jobs higher taxes
a weaker economy and
my honourable friend is absolutely right
what have we seen under the
Conservatives in government we've seen
3.4 million more that's more people
earning an income earning a wage able to
provide for their families we've seen
more children in good and outstanding
schools more money into our National
Health Service
what would put that in danger a
government led by the right honourable
gentleman more borrowing more taxes more
spending fewer jobs
Thank You mr. speaker thank you may I
start by correcting the record last
night I suggested this was the largest
government defeat since the 1920s I
would not wish to be accused of
misleading the house I've since been
informed that is in fact the largest
ever defeat for a government in the
history of our democracy
[Music]
so mr. speaker shortly after the Prime
Minister made her point of order last
night her spokesperson suggested the
government had ruled out any form of
customs union with the European Union as
part of her reaching out exercise can
the Prime Minister confirm that's the
case the exercise that I indicated last
night is as I said about listening to
the views of the house about wanting to
understand the views of parliamentarians
so that we can identify what could
command the support of this house and
deliver on the referendum and what the
government wants to do is first of all
to ensure that we deliver on the result
of the referendum that's leaving the
European Union and we want to do it in a
way that ensures we respect the votes of
those who voted to leave in that
referendum that means ending free
movement it means getting a fair a deal
for farmers and fishermen it means it
means opening up new opportunities to
trade with the rest of the world and it
means keeping good ties with our
neighbors in Europe my question was
you're watching questions there in the
British House of Commons to Theresa May
on what is another historic day for
Britain we are joined by our
correspondent Alex Forrest whiting what
do you make of what we've seen so far
well the very first question that was
put to her was by one of her own
backbenchers Charlie elphic who is
basically giving was giving her an
opportunity to say the Conservative
government is still the best government
to have in place and we have done the
most for the country and that is because
the government is going to be facing a
no-confidence vote later today which
we'll talk about in a second and then we
had Jeremy Corbyn the leader of the
Labour Party that's the main opposition
party again saying you know really
trying to make him even more difficult
for Theresa May this was not just the
worst defeat in almost a hundred years
for a government this was the worst
defeat he's the largest government
defeat in history of democracy in the UK
and making it very clear that you know
what is she going to do next
the Labour Party would like the UK to
stay in a permanent customs union to
resume does not want that to happen and
certainly those breaks of Tears do not
want that to happen and given all of
this going back and forth here I mean
it's an extremely difficult day for
Teresa may for Britain for brexit it's a
very difficult day for Teresa may she's
got to get through half an hour of being
questioned by MPs in Parliament yet
again then because of this no confidence
vote that's going to happen later today
MPs are going to be given a few hours in
Parliament to debate whether there is
confidence in the government and that
will be labour and the other opposition
parties trying to make it as difficult
as possible for Tory but in taking like
she might win it it is looking like she
may well we're not going to let's get
some more on what could perhaps be a
worst case scenario though um get some
details into this because if she on the
other hand loses the confidence vote it
could trigger a general election in
fresh chaos for the acrimonious brexit
process but not everyone in London seems
afraid of that have a listen for remain
supporters gathered outside the British
Parliament Teresa may's humiliation was
a sign of hope defeat for the Prime
Minister's brags it deal coup to open
the door to a so-called people's vote a
second referendum on EU membership eyes
to the right 202 the nose to the left
432 despite her rezoning defeat Theresa
May says she is determined to deliver
brexit to the British people but even
some within her own party believe a
second referendum is now the only option
parliamentarians do have some duties and
one of them is to prevent people from
committing national suicide a No Deal
brexit does that first may face is a
no-confidence vote in her government the
rebels within her party have signaled
that they will back her position is
secure unless the very precisely worded
nation tomorrow goes through which seems
very unlikely she emphasized that she'd
come in to deliver brexit and that that
was what she was going to do such faith
is in short supply in today's British
newspapers and the Labour Mayor of
London a city that voted overwhelmingly
against brexit also added his weight to
calls for a fresh referendum surely the
best option is to give the British
public I say for the first time or
whether they accept the Prime Minister's
deal with the option of remaining in the
evening there's no need for this panic
but for some panic is clearly beginning
to set in business is booming at this
English storage firm with companies
stockpiling Goods and fear of an ordeal
inspired catastrophe in just over two
months time that's really the point I
mean it's in just over two months time
Alex that that Briggs it is scheduled to
take place um if May does win this no
confidence vote today what happens next
so she then has she said just that we
heard earlier that she is listening to
the house as she's reaching out to
parliamentarians in the House of Commons
to try to find a consensus within
Parliament that people can agree to but
she still said with by delivering the
result of the referendum from 2016 which
is that the UK will leave the EU now
already one of her spokespeople has said
that they do not want to delay brexit
there was talk about extending article
50 of the Lisbon Treaty which will give
the the UK a little bit longer to try to
sort itself out she's saying they've
said again they don't want that to
happen however the EU itself has said
that that is an option if the UK would
like to take it so she's got to try and
reach out
commentaries she has to come back to
Parliament on Monday with a plan B and
the big question is what is her plan B
going to be given how how difficult it
is within Parliament to reach any
consensus you have those who want to
leave those who are willing to leave on
a No Deal and those who want a second
referenda and how the EU also might
react to that we had some reaction some
initial gauging of that from the German
Chancellor herself angle Americo a short
while ago I just want to play what she
said and then get your reaction to it
let's have a listen I deeply regret the
fact that the House of Commons has
rejected the agreement on Britain's
departure from the EU we believe it is
now up to the British side to say what
happens next
yes the Prime Minister has announced you
will we want to keep the damage which
will inevitably follow from brexit as
small as possible that is why we will
continue to seek an orderly solution by
tatsu Finn Bob North I still have time
to negotiate but we will wait to see
what the Prime Minister proposes that's
enough
we have time to negotiate that's
interesting it's interesting if there
are 10 weeks left so but but clearly
that is an olive branch to tourism a and
to the UK to say that look we are
listening what more can we do however do
not forget that so far the EU is
standing resolute that they will not
reopen that withdrawal agreement that
was agreed back in November that is
their binding agreement that is legally
binding 585 pages they don't want to
reopen it and that is what has upset
many breaks to tears because they want
significant changes to it what they can
perhaps do is offer some more in this
political declaration particularly over
Northern Ireland to try to prevent a
hard border between Northern Ireland and
the Republic of Ireland ever returning
and that is a big threat because of
brexit so there we hear it Angela Merkel
saying that she will that they will
listen they will do what they can but
really it has to come down to Teresa may
it has to
down to Parliament what does the UK want
what does Parliament want and as I said
before there is no consensus
you know British politics so well Alex I
mean if you had to go out on a limb here
what do you expect to happen in the
coming days in the coming weeks I think
that we're going to see Parliament and
peace take more control there's already
plans afoot on Monday to try to force
the government into allowing
parliamentarians to take more control
they're going to say to the government
you've got three weeks to come up with
another plan if you don't then it's
going to come down to the very senior MP
those who head up various departments
within Parliament to try to reach a
consensus and those heads of those
committees you have brexit ears you have
those who want a second referendum so
they're hoping that maybe they can come
to some agreement I think we are
possibly heading more towards a softer
brexit I mean there is obviously still a
very real threat that the UK leaves with
no deal but I think Parliament doesn't
want that to happen we could be heading
towards a softer brexit or maybe just
maybe a second referendum if the Labour
Party on to Jeremy Corbyn decide that
that that is the route that they will go
down at the moment it is not seems as if
all options are still on the table Alex
Forrest fighting I think we've seen it
all we appreciate your analysis
you